the the fact that the right ends seem to
be
um give a nice like spark
of uh beauty to the whole experience i
don't know i don't know if it can be
improved easily it
could be more beautiful i don't know how
yeah
what do you mean what do you mean how
all the ways you can't imagine
no but that's the whole point i wouldn't
be able to and that the fact that i can
imagine ways in
in which it could be more beautiful
means so do you know you know
ian banks his stories so the
the super smart ais there live
mostly live in the world of what they
call infinite fun
because they can create arbitrary
worlds so they interact and you know the
story has it they interact in the normal
world and they're very smart and they
can do all kinds of stuff
and you know a given mind can you know
talk to a million humans at the same
time because we're very slow and
for reasons you know artificial the
story they're interested in people and
doing stuff but
they mostly live in this this other land
of thinking
my inclination is to think that the
ability to create
infinite fun will uh will not be so fun
that's sad there's so many things to do
imagine be able to make a star
move planets around yeah yeah but
because we can imagine that
is why life is fun if we can if we
actually were able to do it it'd be a
slippery slope
where fun wouldn't even have a meeting
because we just consistently
desensitize ourselves by the infinite
amounts of fun we're having
the sadness uh the the dark stuff is
what makes it fun
i think i mean that could be the russian
it could be the could be the fun makes
it fun and the sadnesses
makes it bittersweet yeah that's true
fun could be the thing that makes it fun
you